It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
Yo!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're here with some FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 121st episode!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Did you wake up well?
Hi.
Fuwawa, I still feel sleepy.
What?
What are you talking about?
Hi.
Ruffians, why are you confused?
Did you wake up on the wrong paw?
What do you think, Moco-chan?
Fuwawa, we're just gonna have to make sure that we get them onto the right paw then.
We'll just go again.
BAU BAU!
Well, for those Ruffians that are joining us for the first time, I feel sorry for you but, FUWAMOCO Morning, the hashtag Morning Show, held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday, aka FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please fill your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I think we might have some bad news.
Oh no.
What is it, Moco-chan?
Ruffians.
There's been another... Pero Sighting!
Why was he spotted this time, Moco-chan?
Killer.
Dead.
Gosh, are Pokey and Pero both fighting?
It's almost like Pero wants to replace Pokey!
Ruffians!
Did you think that Pero was Pokey this whole time?
No, that's Pokey.
Pokey's kinda weird though, huh, Ruffians?
Huh?
Yeah.
Up 10 anime battles?
What do you mean by that, huh?
I don't like how Pokey moves.
You know, it's like watching an oil spill spread across a field of flowers.
Nasty.
Ruffians.
Who would you cheer for here, huh?
Pokey?
Pero?
It's like balloons.
No.
Not balloons.
Ruffians!
I cheer for neither.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU.
Neither you cheer for FUWAMOCO.
Really?
You cheer for Mococo!
BAU BAU!
And for Fuwawa, right?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians!
You know, not too long ago, it was our first year anniversary celebration.
Do you remember?
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Wow, we also shared our newest song, Born to be BAU with you.
Moco-chan, be quiet.
Of course, right?
You remember, right?
Even bamboo, that's good!
Yeah!
But also!
We have some new anniversary merch that we share with you too!
Yeah!
Yeah, do you remember?
De-den!
BAU BAU!
Have you gotten your paws on the real Ruffians?
Yes!
Let's take a look at them!
Yeah!
First, we have
Are FUWAMOCO happy puppy happy?
There it is!
Are happy puppy happy?
You know, perfect for concerts like Breaking Dimensions.
You know, these won't be quite ready for Breaking Dimensions, but you'll still be able to wear it before the next big concert, right?
And a Pero pussy.
Yeah!
He's normally very nasty as you know, Ruffians.
But this Pero pussy here
Actually, extremely cute.
Is that okay to say, Moco-chan?
I said it.
Yeah.
So, Ruffians!
You might want to get one just so you can kick around.
Just like I did.
I hug sometimes too.
What?
Never know.
Well, we also have the BAU BAU Voice Key Team!
You know, we can BAU BAU wherever you go!
You can always hear our voice, right?
BAU BAU!
And also, our FUWAMOCO Pair Glasses!
You know, it's super cute!
And very helpful keeping you hydrated while watching our streams!
Yeah, you need it!
Yeah!
Very very good, yeah.
Well, we hope that you'll check these out in the hololive official shop!
You know, pre-orders end at 6pm September 2nd, JST!
What's wrong Fuwawa?
Nothing, I just felt like you were sort of funny, huh?
Something may be a bit funny, huh?
Something's just funny.
No!
Just a regular FUWAMOCO Morning!
No, it just felt like it was a bit funny, huh?
Yeah.
So make sure you don't miss out on K-Ruffians!
You know, just think that once it's September, your chance is gone.
Yeah.
You know, Ruffians, you know, times only make things tricky.
Ruffians!
Moco-chan, what did you just say?
Well, we can't wait until you get your paws on them, okay?
Make sure you get your paws on them.
Nothing funny is going on.
BAU BAU!
Nothing funny.
Wow.
Ruffians!
Are you feeling a bit hot right now?
Sort of like maybe you have a fever?
Well, actually, FUWAMOCO, we've been having a bunch of fun at the Rio Full Water Park!
BAU BAU!
Along with a bunch of our super heroes!
And, fun at the water park also means swimsuits!
Swimsuits!
Ruffians!
Do you see here?
We even have our own water slide!
BAU BAU!
There's so much to do and so much to eat and get your paws on.
You know, there's also...
A lot of merchandise as well!
That's cute!
That
FUWAMOCO also have water slide, right?
But Ayame-senpai!
Ayame-senpai have water slide out of Ayame-senpai's mouth, you know?
Fukura-senpai and Ayame-senpai!
I didn't say senbei, no.
Kurasenbei.
What are you saying?
You're saying silly things again!
I wonder why I said it silly today, huh?
Things are strange, huh?
Yeah.
But it'll be funny to slide out of their mouths, huh?
Yeah?
Yeah.
What a wonderful summer memory!
I'm so happy to be a part of this special summer event, Ruffians!
Nothing suspicious.
BAU BAU!
And us.
Ruffians.
Whoa, you're kinda quiet.
A bit reserved today, huh?
Ruffians!
Huh?
We have some confessions to make.
Yeah.
Ruffians!
We've been bad dogs, huh?
You know, as a part of the whole summer bingo!
We have something we need to confess.
We need to confess our things.
Things.
Fuwawa, are you okay?
No, I'm not okay today.
Thank you, Fuwawa.
Are you feeling extra, extra, extra fluffy?
I'm feeling extra fluffy, huh?
You know, we would like to take the time today
To make a wholehearted confession and apology for our sins.
FUWAMOCO!
First, we need to sleep more.
BAU BAU.
In the past few days, Ruffians, we streamed so much YouTube!
YouTube got angry at us and, you know, apparently stopped showing that we were live to Ruffians.
We need to sleep more.
How could YouTube do that to us, huh, Ruffians?
Also, we still have more to confess.
We confessed to checking Ruffians' Twitters to find a tweet we wanted to like, but we didn't.
Because it was at a time that we're Japan.
We should have been asleep.
Or it's too quickly after they posted it.
13 seconds, that's a bit fast.
Yeah.
And then you know Ruffians!
Go to look for it.
Yeah.
But, it's not there!
I can't find it.
You went deleted it!
What the heck Ruffians!
What are you doing?
Ha!
Awesome.
We've confessed to wanting to tweet FUWAMOCHI tweets too.
Thank goodness we did it!
Yeah.
We'll confess.
Do you feel better, Fuwawa?
I'm not Fuwawa!
I'm Mococo!
BAU BAU!
Oh boy!
I'm sorry Ruffians!
That was... technical issues.
I'm sorry Ruffians, I hope you understand.
But you know... Forget about the technical issues because... FORGET!
In just... 2 days!
2 days!
3 days!
Very soon!
There is... Breaking...
BAU BAU!
There's Breaking Dimensions!
Yeah!
And I'm sure you've heard by now, Ruffians, because of all the excitement that's going on, but hololive English's second origi- I mean, second concert, Breaking Dimensions!
What are you saying, original?
It's just hours away!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
Yeah, it's gonna be held at King's Theater in New York, and it'll be the first time we're on the big stage together with all of Advent!
I'm nervous.
It's okay, Moco-chan.
I'll do my best not to cry!
You better!
Okay.
Okay, I promise, Fuwawa.
But you know, F-F-F-Fuwawians who want to be a part of this big, huge stream of life coming too, you can join us from your home online with a streaming ticket from SPWM.
It's fun!
E+.
Yeah!
And then Ruffians!
That way, you can be extra comfy and cheer and dance as loud as you want from your own home!
Yeah!
Exactly!
And Ruffians!
Uh, there are some questions of whether you're allowed to stand at the venue, but you are!
You are!
You just have to make sure you stay standing in your seat area, okay?
Understood!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Make sure to be kind to your neighbors too!
Manners is good!
I want everyone to be like, wow!
Ruffians are amazing!
You know how they like to zoom in close to the audience, right Ruffians?
Ruffians!
Well, we'll be looking to see you dancing along and going crazy bau bauing together with us!
So make sure you're howling up a storm, and we're sure the cameras will find you, okay?
We can't wait to hear your voices, Ruffians!
Are you still feeling a little nervous, Ruffians?
Why don't we practice the calls for BAU BAU one more time before breaking dimensions?
Is that a good idea?
Would you like that, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
One last time before breaking dimensions, okay?
I'm ready, Fuwawa!
Are you ready, Ruffians?
Okay.
Yeah, you're good to go.
BAU BAU!
And just give Fuwawa a moment, because I'm a bit confused right now.
Okay.
Less confused.
Still confused, but less confused.
Are your pet mice ready, Ruffians?
Okay!
Here we go!
In a moment.
Okay, here we go Ruffians!
3, 2, 1!
Here we go!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAWA!
MOCOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Crop!
Puppy!
BAU BAU BAU!
Crop!
Happy!
Lucky!
Puppy!
Aww!
Here we go now, friends!
Yeah!
Yeah, there we go!
Wahoo!
Come on!
Fuwa fuwa fuwa fuwa!
Hai!
Moco!
Bau bau!
BAU BAU!
Fuwa wai!
Mococo!
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAWA!
MOCOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
CUP!
Busty!
Yuppie!
Ah!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
Yo!
Tiger!
Wahoo!
Come on!
Fuwa fuwa fuwa fuwa!
Hai!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
BAU!
Ya!
Tiger!
Wahoo!
Come on!
Fuwa fuwa fuwa fuwa!
Hi!
Mocho!
BAU BAU!
Okie dokie!
FUWAWA!
MOCOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAWA!
MOCOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
That was fun to be BAUDA!
BAU BAU!
How did you do?
You perfected it!
BAU BAU!
Maybe we're still a bit frazzled this morning, huh?
What?
Fuwawa!
Have you woken up on the wrong paw?
Maybe I'm just a bit frazzled today.
I feel a bit funny, huh?
Maybe...
Maybe a bit harder than normal, huh?
A little fuzzy, but you should be fluffy!
A bit.
Yeah.
You're a good Ruffians, huh?
Well.
Moco-chan, you know.
It's not the end of the week, right?
I guess I could say something to the Ruffians!
Maybe to give you a little bit of
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Do you know what day it is?
Yeah, you should!
Because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear straight from me.
Mococo!
Ruffians, have you been a bit excited recently?
So much, maybe so much excitement that you feel a bit scared.
That's okay!
That's natural!
Maybe you've been even feeling a bit sad too.
Because sometimes there are exciting things going on and you want to go so badly!
But no matter what, it's just not possible.
Ruffians!
That's totally normal.
We can't do everything we want to do all the time.
It's just not possible.
But that doesn't mean that you can't enjoy things through other ways that are accessible to you.
Maybe you can't go directly to an event, but maybe there's a livestream, or people live-tweeting their photos, or stories online, or even friends you can talk to!
Huh?
It's understandable to be a bit upset or have cloudy feelings, but rather than saying sad that you can't be there yourself, try to be thankful that there are still other ways to experience things and enjoy the moment together.
You know, don't let it ruin something that could otherwise be so much fun and amazing.
Just because you can't enjoy it 100% doesn't mean you shouldn't enjoy it 80%.
So, you know, let's all have fun together, okay?
Because, you know, we're always thinking about you, no matter where you are.
We're going to have so much fun all together this weekend, okay?
So keep doing your best and stay safe as we break the dimensions!
Ganbatte ne!
Thank you, Moco-chan.
That was a very nice pup talk, huh?
That was a clip of you.
I'm Mococo!
That was a clip.
I'm Fuwawa!
Oh boy.
Well, should we move on to our story of the day?
BAU BAU!
Well, our doggy of the day for today is... De-den!
Today's doggy of the day is... Katie!
Katie!
BAU BAU!
We're a little shy!
She looks tiny, but she barks loudly!
Don't underestimate her, okay?
I'm not going, no.
Yeah.
Moco-chan, how does Katie BAU BAU?
BAU BAU!
It does.
It's pretty noisy, really.
BAU BAU!
Huh?
Well, kitty, you know, she looks super sweet, but she's a strong girl dog just like FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
Man, nobody stands in her way.
Except for, uh, silly bugs when they get in the house.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Huh.
And next... FUWAMOCO we go on a walk!
Huh?
For today, I went on a walk.
Oh, where do we go, Ruffians?
De-den!
Oh!
We went on a nice camping trip!
FUWAMOCO!
We're so happy that you were able to disconnect.
Have a little bit and enjoy some time with your family.
Especially, you know, with your little cousin there too.
Yeah, that must have been so nice.
Wish it was such a very special first camping trip for them.
Huh?
BAU BAU!
And... For the question of the day... De-den!
De-den!
Ah, today's question of the day.
Hey FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Many Ruffians will be streaming Breaking Dimensions at home.
How would you watch it if you were in their shoes?
Sitting in a comfy chair with lots of tasty snacks?
Or singing along and dancing and jumping around with penlights?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
The best way is to watch it however you feel is the most fun to you!
Definitely right, FUWAMOCO-chan.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe with snacks or pamlets or friends.
Make sure you eat a lot of snacks.
Yeah, we definitely enjoyed dancing and singing and waving penlights around the best bar!
Right, Fuwawa?
So many times we've done that!
Yeah, lots of memories waving the penlights and crying to idol concert DVDs!
What's important is that you have fun yourself.
Got it, Ruffians?
Huh?
Got it.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, thank you so much for all of your submissions!
Remember, FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make all together!
So we're always looking forward to more doggy of a days, to seeing your walks, and your questions, and you know, Pero sightings even if they're really nasty.
Okay, or even the brand new, recently discovered FUWAMOCO school!
Okay, it's been helping us lots, K-Ruffians!
Don't forget the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Well, we have another stream coming up, right?
Yes!
Yes, Moco-chan, we do!
What's our next stream?
De-den!
It's not really a stream.
Cheering Space!
No more streams for this week.
No more FUWAMOCO Mornings for this week.
Just breaking dimensions!
Yeah, Ruffians!
Why are you so quiet, FUWAMOCO-chan?
Are you laughing at me?
I'm not laughing!
I'm Mococo!
But you can cheer for us at the cheering space, okay, Ruffians?
Okay!
Yeah!
That would make us happy, huh?
BAU BAU!
And our schedule.
Do we need to look at the schedule, FUWAMOCO?
Just in case you didn't know, Breaking Dimensions
BAU BAU!
And for Ruffians who are joining us in the archive today, here's your FUWAMOCO word!
It's BAU BAU BREAKING THE MANSIONS WITH YOU!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some more of our extra special Ruffians!
Cheesecake desu!
BAU BAU!
Porcine.
Nickels bag.
BAU BAU!
Kitsuneko.
Garnocks.
BAU BAU!
Aspie.
Cabernet.
BAU BAU!
Twilight!
Aojiru Moshi!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, I hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
That was wrong.
I'm not Mococo!
I'm Fuwawa!